we were totally shocked by your decision
Elsa we've really thought that you would
go back to arendelle with Anna after all
you are doing a great job as Queen but
honey Marin was right you really do
belong in the Enchanted Forest you'll be
closer to a to Holland where your powers
come from and you can get closer to all
the other spirits plus it's not like
you're that far from your family but
what does this mean for the future of
arendelle chosen to had a pretty
satisfying ending but fans are already
dreaming up plots for a third movie we
have to admit a lot of these van
theories make total sense keep watching
for the best theories about frozen three
the ending of frozen - we can't believe
everything that happened in frozen -
there were a lot of storylines that had
to get wrapped up first honor realized
that the only way to free the forest was
to destroy the dam the dam had been
built by her grandfather who used it to
trick the North aldrin it destroyed
their resources and her grandfather
attacked the tribes which angered the
spirits so they cut off the forest from
the rest of the world when Anna
destroyed the dam she also freed Elsa
who had been frozen in a ttle Holland
this made all his powers complete as the
fifth spirit she is the one who can
unite and calm the other spirits she
arrived just in time with the knock to
save arendelle from being destroyed by
the flood Elsa used her magic to bring
Olaf back to life water has memory and
snow is just frozen water
Kristoff finally proposed to Anna and
also realized that she belonged in the
forest with the other spirits causing
ahna to become the queen of arendelle
frozen to was beyond epic and it's got
fans talking some are convinced that a
third and final installment is a shoo-in
and first and three theories are flying
around the internet as though they were
being guided by Gale herself Kristoff
can I borrow your wagon and spend em I'm
not very comfortable with the idea of
that Elsa's forest adventures the first
frozen three theory is all about Elsa
she's no longer the queen of arendelle
so what will she do with all of her time
one theory about Elsa is that she'll
finally get a love interest plenty of
fans notice some serious chemistry
between honey Marin and the ice queen
there are lots of fans who would love
to see an Elsa love story also now that
the Enchanted Forest is open again it
can be totally safe some people in
arendelle still fear magic like Elsa's
grandfather or maybe news of the forest
will travel to the rest of the world
someone else will come and try to use
the magic of the forest also we'll have
to stop them she could also figure out
more about her parents she never did
decode that parchment she and Anna found
in the shipwreck the North aldrin said
that her mother was from one of the
oldest families in their culture but we
don't meet this family Elsa might go try
to find her distant relatives Princess
Anna is dead
Hans returns can we all agree that Hans
is pretty much the worst in the first
movie he's determined to take over
arendelle here's the thing about Hans
though he's the annoying little brother
of a huge family his chances of ever
ruling a kingdom are pretty slim
that's why you tried to woo on it and
get rid of Elsa he figured it was his
best shot at becoming king of anything
Hans might hear that honest now the
queen of arendelle he could think that
it's safe to come to try again because
Elsa isn't there Hans might even
convince his father or some of his
brothers to help him there could be a
whole army Anna would need Elsa to come
down from the forest to help save
arendelle again Hans is also totally the
type of person to try and take over the
enchanted forest
Hans would have gotten along great with
Ana's grandfather he could end up
fighting the North Waldron's and then
the forest might become cursed again
only Elsa and Anna can save the forest
are you totally obsessed with Disney fan
theories so are we be the first to watch
the hottest series about Disney movies
when you subscribe to the things want to
be notified about new videos make sure
your mobile YouTube settings are set to
allow notifications now let's get back
to frozen three theories keep watching
to find out what could happen with
Kristoff and Ana's children frozen a
prequel we were absolutely fascinated by
the story of Anna and Elsa's parents it
would be so cool to see more about them
we know what happened with arendelle
attacking the north all drones but what
happened before that
we would love to see what Queen I do
know was like when she was growing up
and then there's the whole question of
what happened after her where did I do
not go after she saved
we'd be really curious to know how I do
know made a life for herself as a young
girl all alone we also have to wonder
what else was going on in arendelle
people had to be pretty upset about the
forest being sealed off and Eichner
became King that very same day but he
was just a boy
he had a lot to learn and never had time
to grieve another possibility for a
prequel could happen way before I Doonan
Agner the North aldrin czar in ancient
people Elsa was probably not the first
person with powers we think a movie
about the ancient north old ruins would
be so cool
it could explain all about the magic of
the forest why is there only magic in
the forest we think there was probably a
time when magic was outside of the
forest to take a look at the trolls
they're made of stone just like the
earth Giants they're just a lot smaller
grandpappy has some magical abilities he
was able to heal Anna and erase her
memories as a kid he can see the future
a prequel could explain all about the
trolls and their magic how did they get
to arendelle there are so many questions
that still need to be answered and
prequels are a great way to do that
there could also be a prequel about what
happened when the forest sealed off it
was a magical place but something went
wrong the North aldrin and though
arendelle soldiers were trapped for 34
years they were constantly at odds with
each other we would love to see how the
soldiers learned how to survive the
North aldrin whole way of life had to
change to can you imagine not being able
to really see the sky for decades they
were also used to using the forest magic
the spirits help them with their
day-to-day life but after the forest was
sealed from the outside world
the spirits kind of disappeared that is
until Elsa woke them with her song it
would be cool to see what was happening
in the forest during those three decades
Anna and Kristoff Anna and Kristoff are
seriously couple goals these two are
just so and loved there are way more
realistic than a lot of Disney couples
back up while I deal with this crook
here
if I did you call me
Christophe adores honor he helps her
instead of just trying to protect her
we're so glad he finally got over his
awkwardness and proposed at the end of
frozen to Ana's announced as the queen
of arendelle but it's not clear whether
or not she's married yet Kristoff gets
all dressed up along with Sven and Olaf
for Ana's special day so if they aren't
married yet frozen three could be about
the royal wedding but it can't just be
an easy wedding there would have to be
some major adventure perhaps Hans comes
back and kidnap Sanne
maybe Kristoff and Sven get lost while
they're out exploring and on and Olaf
have to find them either way we really
want to see a wedding Kristoff
attempting to write his own vows would
be so cute I also would have to come
back to be maid of honor of course we
cast Fenn would be the best man grand
pabbie would perform the ceremony you
have to admit it would be the best
wedding ever a spinoff everyone loves
the main characters from frozen Anna and
Elsa are awesome Kristoff and Sven are
so much fun to have around and Olaf is
the cutest and most hilarious snowman
ever but there are plenty of other
characters that were introduced these
characters were so cool we'd love a
story about general Matthias and his
lost love in arendelle Ryder is also a
supercool character he was so excited to
see what life was like outside of the
forest maybe he and the reindeer go on
some grand adventure then there's honey
Marin we want to know so much more about
this character she is really amazing but
she's kind of mysterious we think there
could be a ton of spin-offs based on the
minor characters from frozen to the next
generation you serious and it's the
latest model
no I can't accept this you have to no
returns
now that Kristoff and honor are getting
married there will probably be a whole
new generation it would be cool to have
a movie all about on and Christoph's
children but what would it be about
well we think there's a good chance that
at least one of them will be magical
think about it on
Haffner Aldrin also was given her powers
as a gift it was because her mother
saved her father and got him out of the
forest then the forest sealed and her
father tried to make things right as the
king but he didn't really understand the
past Donna helped the forest - she
destroyed the dam to save it
she broke the curse and freed the people
her children could be blessed with magic
powers - but Anna will know better than
to force her kids to conceal their
powers look what it did to Elsa in the
first movie see concede but Anna will
also know that she needs help we think a
movie about Ana's future daughter going
to the forest to live with her on Elsa
would be so awesome also would teach her
niece how to use her magic and since
she's starting so young she might become
more powerful than Elsa also can you
imagine how cute Anna and Kristoff
children would be they'd grow up with
Olaf and Sven to play with it would be
cool and adorable we really hope that
one day we get a movie all about the
next frozen generation that's a rat
which of these theories do you like best
for frozen 3 do you have your own
theories about a future movie let us
know in the comments section thanks for
watching give this video a big thumbs up
if you want more frozen 3 videos we'll
catch you next time
you
[Music]